u n
h
r e m n a asks
what is a theolocution
okay so
let's see i wrote this down
you can
think of a theolocution as an
advancement of knowledge rather than a
destruction which is generally the style
of debates
and that a theolocution is couched in
tenderness and respect so socrates used
questions and answers to generate new
knowledge that's called the socratic
method though he did so privately and if
it was in public the point of it wasn't
to do it publicly and he also did it
sardonically now contrasting this the
way that i like to think about the
what a theo locution is is the socratic
method plus
an audience
plus fondness so that equals a
theolocution if you want to think of it
as a equation
so your ancestors danny says are from
india
indeed i am from toronto i was born in
trinidad my parents are from trinidad my
ancestors say the great great
great grandparents are from the west
indies ryan says ah shucks miss the ama
how can we know how to enter an ama and
when they come up whether this is my ama
or an ama with let's say pious salvator
pious and so on so i announce all of
what i plan on doing generally
far in advance on patreon and i give an
indication as to the direction for the
next few months regularly this is in
contrast to a call for questions which
are which are generally done openly on
the youtube page
so
if you want you can
sign up for the patreon
just so you know the patreon is the
virtually the only way that i'm able to
do this the other ways with the sponsor
so i'm
super super grateful for the sponsors
and for and for the patrons people who
donate
out of the kindness generosity
of their own heart
when they have
when there's no
obligation to do so it's incentive free
there is one tier
so when i say it's incentive free that
is to say you don't get any
special invites on patreon you don't get
any special access on patreon
there is one tier though a meta field
theorist here which just opened up about
a month ago
where you can speak to myself for about
an hour or so along with others who are
on the group call it's limited to about
six people and people seem to have
enjoyed it for the previous one for an
additional benefit that i didn't foresee
which is networking
someone recently wanted some metal
printing done and someone else there was
in that field and someone wanted help
getting his toe more known and someone
said that they knew how to
pair silicon valley investors up with
people who are interested in having
their toe or sorry having some personal
intellectual endeavor
conducted there's someone who i think
about
every once in a while his name is
voltaire i don't think i've ever
mentioned him on the podcast
and voltaire had a phrase where he said
that he has made himself
he's made himself dependent in order to
become independent and i feel like
that's a great way of summarizing what
patreon is the reason i'm mentioning it
here is because many people who are on
the
who are patrons have said they would
never have known about it had i not
mentioned it
and i remember saying i mentioned in
virtually every episode they say oh i
just i've listened to you for a year and
i haven't heard it until just yesterday
well that's because many people skipped
the intros so i'm
i'm deeply grateful i view it like
busking it's a shameful plug you know
people say this is a shameless plug and
so on i feel some shame it's
embarrassing
though i tend to view it like busking
where the
podcast is is able to be enjoyed
entirely for free
like a musical performance or a magic
trick except it's a podcast in this case
and then you choose to pay in fact it's
even more anonymous than busking because
you don't have the added social pressure
of people around you and then the end
where everyone claps and you have to
awkwardly walk away there's no
obligation even here this comes with a
time stamp somewhere where you can skip
this whole spiel because
i feel like the
firstly i don't like to be talked to in
this manner when it comes to someone
advertising the ways to support them or
sponsors and so on and all of these come
with a timestamp somewhere here or here
where they say you can skip this
introduction
or sponsor message because
well i don't want to force or trick
anyone into listening to what they
didn't intend to listen to and what that
does is it
radically reduces the amount that a
sponsor is willing to pay
and the amount that people would sign up
to patreon because like i mentioned
someone has
watched for a year and then had no idea
that i even had a patreon but i feel
like in the long run the trust that's
engendered by
putting up a timestamp or a method for
you to click out of this such that you
don't feel manipulated into listening to
something you didn't want to
that that will lead to a better
relationship with
with you with the people who are
watching with the patrons and with the
sponsors so in the short run it's not
it's not terribly great monetarily but
hopefully in the long run it is and my
wife my wife is extremely grateful for
all the support she is more grateful in
many ways than i am and that's saying
plenty so if you're
supporting or not just by watching thank
you i i appreciate your eyes i
appreciate whatever it's
it's i'm in an extremely blessed
position so thank you as for the sponsor
today's sponsor is brilliant and
brilliant like i mentioned before
brilliance is a place that you can go to
to view
interactive learning experiences on
statistics and mathematics and physics
you can learn about group theory you can
learn about entropy i
over the winter break the 2021 december
2022 january was studying about entropy
because i wanted to learn why is it that
the formula for entropy is written in
this manner and
it becomes extremely clear extremely
lucid and perspicuous why s equals lawn
or log of the amount of states is an
extremely natural
way of
categorizing the information held in a
system and that it would be strange to
define it in any other manner
that comes from brilliant that my
knowledge of that comes from brilliance
and that's going to help me when i
eventually get to speak to chiara
marletto or david deutsch on their
constructor theory so visit
brilliant.org tow to get 20 off your
annual subscription